yo what's up everybody it's comedian TK
Kirkland AKA t to the [__] gay
and you can catch me on the bootleg Kev
podcast and may your pain be champagne
peace
peace it's the bootleg cat podcast we
got a special guest in here very special
guest come on now he brought a cigar I
brought a joint TK Kirkland is here
what's up everybody he's back yes
welcome man thank you fam well listen we
were just talking about how you thought
uh my co-host James uh is very unhealthy
he looks by the way I walk he gives you
unhealthy Vibes yes he does what was it
about my walk that you've seen you look
unhealthy and that you was gonna die
this year damn chance don't take care of
your health well yeah you know what man
because I don't go to doctors I haven't
been in like a decade yeah that's not
that's not that's not that's not good
fam the other thing about James is James
is um I've like been working with him
about two years the entire time
he works out every morning and he he you
work out every morning every morning but
he stays the same weight he's not
working out no I'm working out he got my
Apple Fitness and he tells you how many
calories no no no you ain't working out
[__] I don't know who you lying to
I see I could see you going in the gym
walking around looking at looking at
equipment and touching it like this like
I can see you doing this like I went you
know I see you touching it yeah
he went to the gym so how much weight
you lost uh so I lost 100 pounds before
the pandemic gained all that back now
lost about 40. okay so so listen stop
playing with your weight stop going up
and down
and the reason why I tell this because
I've been on this planet a long time
I've seen so many people when they
fluctuate with their weight right and
what happens is that to me what I've
seen it causes Strokes laid on Down the
Line it causes um heart attacks because
that's stress on your heart
going up and going down you know what I
mean and this is something I think is um
like we was all off the air I I think
this is a great thing to talk about
health because we always talk about
music
we always talk about relationships but
we never money talk I'm talking about
money but we never talk about health and
we want to teach these kids and women
and everybody start going to the doctor
let's let's start putting that out in
the universe that we take care of
ourselves you know so that's important
okay we appreciate you returning yeah
thank you uh you're our first interview
in the new spot by the way Super Bowl
week interviews brought to you by Def
Jam shout out to Def Jam uh but I wanted
to talk to you because there was a clip
that went viral of you recently yeah you
were on Vlad and it was essentially you
saying now I'll let you kind of women
have a certain time period to report if
they've been sexually assaulted yes was
it an hour it was an hour to report it
okay now I want you to yes I'm going to
elaborate please because that sounds
crazy yeah this sounds crazy and the
reason why and everybody that hit me
from all over the world
was basing everything on their personal
experience
so I did this interview with this young
lady and we I I explained I explained to
her what I felt right and I explained
and I listened to what she said and what
I'll tell the world when I tell you guys
see everybody when they hear certain
things
is based on your journey in life right
see we all have a flight pattern in life
and right now I'm sitting here at this
table we have landed so all your
experiences right now is going to come
out
as we're talking if I say certain things
to you you're going to feel a certain
way based on your journey right that has
led you here so with the young lady she
said how she had got assaulted and that
um she this particular woman says she
felt like it was going to be unnecessary
to say anything because she felt like
the cops um
wouldn't take us seriously that she
wouldn't be playing and then
um when I was listening to her I said
you know what you write but I say I want
to listen won't you listen to me now
into the world who's watching when I say
that you have an hour
what happens if you do it with an hour
whether that person whether the cops
believe you or not
and that person who violated you gets
noticed that he did something wrong you
could probably take that personal
straight but if you
wait a year wait 30 years and he's
really a predator
you give him a chance to get more
victims
over the years but if you get a person
right then you might could get them off
the street you might can get them locked
up that day now everything is based some
women say oh I probably didn't want to
feel comfortable at that time right some
women say well I didn't have the courage
until I saw her such and such did when I
saw her do it
that's what made me do it and
everybody's right so there's no wrong
thank you okay there's no wrong answer
so your thing your thing is just like yo
like my advice to you would be if not
you got an hour or you're [__] yes but
my advice to you would be immediately
reported immediately immediately report
it because you get that person so I
think I think that's a better way yeah I
think that's a lot better than how I I
feel like me and him yeah I agree hey we
were scrolling on I think the shade room
I was like God damn what is no no what
you're saying [__] and what you're
saying is right it's not what I said is
how I said it right I I do think that
that's not bad advice yes right yeah
he's pretty much saying for better
chances to lock somebody up just tell as
quick as possible and if you're a woman
who's going through something and maybe
it's a family member or maybe it's right
more complicated and it takes a little
bit more there's no wrong there's no
wrong that's fair yeah there's no wrong
because and if I offended anybody I
apologize but because I was right I just
worded it the wrong way that everybody
couldn't right understand it that's
important yes they're very important
yeah I remember that we all hear stuff
different so your attention sometimes is
people's perception might take it
differently so yeah you got to clear
your intentions up yes that all makes
sense uh so listen man you are on the
road you're managing yourself your your
podcast is going crazy
um how are you feeling in the New Year
TK how's everything I mean you're
looking good man
here's the thing man um
I loved life so much gentlemen you feel
me like
I really love this thing yeah I really
love life and I teach that and one of my
friends said TK don't die I said what do
you mean she said because most people
with comedians commit suicide because
they depressed or they overdose yeah and
I said I said it's in my DNA I'm a
fly-ass [__] that's exactly what I told
her you know because I said I'm there's
nothing about me that's depressed even
though most comedians they say they hide
in something right right I'm not that
dude
I'm not hiding nothing and I hope I'm an
exception to the rule right I moved
through life happy
um I'm blessed and don't get me wrong
the things I went to when I was hustling
back in the day when I was doing crazy
[__] all this makes me appreciate life
but then I get these constant reminders
like my dreams be so insane I've
murdered people I've gotten robbed in
your dreams in my dreams and when I wake
up I go oh man
right that was a dream but I turned a
negative to positive I say to myself I
think that was a dream I really
appreciate
my life because I could have been all
these other things that I'm dreaming
about so I go to bed like at nine my
daughter's just tripping because I don't
sleep
along that very long she's a dad you
don't sleep long I might sleep four
hours it might be like a whole day
because I feel so good she'll sleep at
nine and wake up at like I'll be up like
about 12 1 o'clock Jesus damn me rolling
for the net but it feels like I slept
the whole right like eight nine ten
hours and what I um say to people is
just funny I say um
is because I love life so much
that I got to get all my minutes out
this month 's mother yeah you only got
one I have one I won every minute
[__] coming to me yeah that's how
much I love this [__] let me ask you
this like it feels like over the last
like uh
10 years or so there's been kind of like
a cool I mean it's probably always been
this way
I feel like you kind of move outside of
the comedy industry explain I feel like
when we think of like some of the bigger
comp like comedians right it feels like
it's real clicky yes yes it's like a
cool game Cool Guy club and it feels
like you're just existing out like
almost like you're an independent rapper
yes yes does that make sense that's so
true you know what I mean like there's
like there's guys who are like a part of
like the machine of Comedy right and
there's TK who's just thriving in his
own right yeah booking his own shows
right just run it up is that fair to say
yeah I always say Eagles Fly alone you
know so I'm an eagle I fly alone I love
seeing what people doing
um
but I move at my own beat and I love
that you know and
um I don't think nobody's a more
brilliant manager than me nobody's more
brilliant in getting that money to me
nobody's more brilliant about health and
and knowledge and it's a shame I gotta
pretty much keep it to myself but when I
do get an OG a young youngster right to
Mentor I give him some
um Gamers here and one of the kids I'm
I'm getting drawn to because he really
listens as a young comedian named Louis
belt and Lewis belt when I see him he's
always oh gee I'm I'm gang keep teaching
me keep teaching me and he really
[__] listen so every time I see him
um that energy is getting connected and
I'm thinking about pulling them over in
a minute and really dropping the OG 101
game on how to move through this because
I want to retire
in about three years I want to retire
but um a man told me years ago young man
named David claim he said TK never
retired because he'll die and this kind
of Lifestyle does keep you yeah
I smell good yeah you know what I'm
saying like I take my [__] serious I
gotta stay well shaved and all that yeah
you got to be presentable anyway you
know so it's it's a good thing so I I'm
I I maybe I might retire I might not or
I might really just go start doing
something else and do shows once a month
like you know um I might do it that way
we'll see but every day I wake up the
phone is my my emails my
did something happen with like a
previous manager or did you just always
man I've always managed so you need to
go through no [__] yeah I know
[__] and agencies have tried to book
me CAA William Morris
um all these people but when I've talked
to them after two or three months they
were like yo there's nothing we could do
for you and I it's not that I want to
share my money I had this horrible
feeling
I gotta call you to find someone who
booked me yeah oh I gotta wait for you
to call me and say such booktube that
got to be a horrible [__] feeling
right that somebody tell you when you're
gonna eat I can't do it yo I feel you on
there I can't do that [__] are you
consuming like any comedy as a fan
because Netflix drops it feels like two
or three specials a week at this point
like are you are you tapping into like
other comedian specials just to kind of
see what they're doing or no no no I I
tell comedians I had this one rule never
watch another comic um
you could
take a peek but never watch another
comment because maybe subconsciously
something happens there that you don't
you watch yep you watch them and they
funny and the next thing you know you
either flip the joke
or you got they style and if you ever
watched my stand on my shit's so cold
that it might have said it best he said
you still TK Kirkland [__] you know it's
TK because nobody talks the way I talk
or think the way that I think and when
in the 90s
when I was trying to pursue HBO going to
meetings show time going to meetings
because that was kind of like the that
was the Pinnacle of Comedy like get in
games and I was always my mindset was
always ahead of my time being
independent and you kids came along and
I always knew in the 90s that my career
was going to change based on youngsters
like you because I didn't know what it
was us I didn't I didn't know there was
gonna be podcast right I didn't know
there was gonna be this streaming thing
I just knew something was going to
happen my world is going to change when
the young kids get older and then bam we
have this new life and entertainment you
know like now I have my own network
right right I don't have to go to HBO
I don't have to go to Netflix but most
convenience people consider brainwashed
I gotta do Netflix
I gotta have my show that's true but I
do my own [__] making my own way like
you said like an independent rapper yeah
it feels like the comedy
um
I guess the
measurables of what makes you a
successful comedian is changing now
because because now you'll see guys like
Andrew scholes or Joe Rogan or the 85
South guys yes and they're have they
have their own platform that's way
bigger than any Netflix show yes that's
bigger than doing a special and selling
it like I think Andrew scholes went he
probably I mean he made millions of
dollars I did a show a couple years ago
it's good to see what he's done but I do
the same thing so it's like it's like it
feels like that at least the tide is
turning in the comedy World in terms of
like
back in the day you almost had to have a
sitcom or or catch a movie Yes or catch
one of those roles to kind of be
considered like and what you guys are
these podcasts that taper do your thing
you guys are the the new Arsenio Hall
shows the new David Letterman right see
because back then you go I'm the only
shows you could get on and you would
only have like three or four minutes at
a time exactly as opposed to sit down
for an hour and people really know
exactly the world watches yeah guys show
the world Listen to My podcast the world
Listen to Vlad the world listens to The
Breakfast Club you know so
um it's really down to honors but it's
been a blessing for me how important has
Vlad been in terms you got that ring
camera going crazy I didn't even know my
[__] was on I thought it was your phone
yeah I thought it was you okay yeah
okay I got security cameras around the
house
um but how important because like I feel
like a lot of people have discovered you
through that platform through Vlad
absolutely
um it feels like you guys got a good
partnership going I love lab man yeah
you know Vlad um I didn't know this was
going to happen it all started like six
seven years ago when I did The Breakfast
Club and I didn't want to do The
Breakfast Club my son did you know yeah
um just like he got me on this yeah yeah
um
my son Eric said to me one day Dad you
should do The Breakfast Club
I saw you [__] with them kids because
I knew Charlemagne when he was the side
yeah
right and um he was a kid so when I
heard about the bird side
ain't got time for that he ain't got
time for that and then my son said dad
and I missed an errors like he's a small
kid okay super smart and um I said okay
cool and when I did it the numbers were
so I didn't really care I didn't know
about numbers either I didn't know what
that meant I didn't know what views and
all that [__] I didn't care about none
of that and after I did that interview
by the time I touched
the lobby of that
um um hallway at the
um Breakfast Club Blanda called me he
said hey I just saw you on The Breakfast
Club would you like to do Vlad and I
just felt on it because I had just The
Breakfast Club I don't know what the
[__] land is they told me the angels
I went over there and then those numbers
was in the millions The Breakfast Club
was in the millions and I still it still
didn't register now when I walked down
the street
I don't care if I'm in London in Germany
everybody know TK Kirkland y'all and
when my daughter's with me they'd be
looking like you just Dad to us you know
and this is it's just a real good
feeling that I'm getting the recognition
that I always felt I deserved but I had
the ability to calmness to wait and be
patient I didn't Panic you know it was
like playing checkers you know you
checked me so I think all the other
comedians who are hilarious people got
started yeah people people are started
that they know I'm funnier than them
like these it ain't no secret right
every comic
in this game no about t to the
[__] K and when we touch that
[__] mic they confront all they
want they could lie all they want in
front of that crowd but internally they
know yeah when we get on that one
because everybody when you came up you
had to come through me because I had six
clubs yeah in Los Angeles everybody had
to come through TK and I would be able
to shut like Jamie Foxx said on this
interview one he said every every comic
in the world is afraid of TK Kirkland he
said because TK can go in the club at a
dance club and shut the [__]
down
you could be in it it could be a dance
it could be dancing I get the
[__] quiet turn that [__] out
wow true story yo and that's why I love
being on the tours I was on back in the
day but
um DMX
babying them the Cash Money Millionaires
um Madonna
um I mean I talked with everybody and no
one no real not true every Community
can't handle that especially a rap tour
you did the Madonna tour I did Madonna
too oh wow yeah I did Madonna did she uh
you know get a little bit of the uh I
mean you feel like her type is all I'll
say yeah yeah see I I met Madonna
through
um a [__] named Haitian Jack
I feel like Haitian Jack is a name I've
heard a lot yeah hasten Jack was the was
the man back in the day and a shout out
to Haitian always show man love the
Asian Jack and he was my uh he was my
muscle okay you know what I'm saying
that sounds like the kind of guy who
yeah hey Jack was my muscle and um you
know I always stay quiet you know I move
a certain way people found out about my
reputation little by little and
um
I went from that type of maybe confused
young man in a sense because I went to
college and ran track right and I had
this error where I was just doing crazy
things and but when I sit and understand
the universe at my age of 62. I
understand all that was meant for me to
be knowledgeable now because when the
podcast is amazing my TK kirkle podcast
is because I've been through so much I
can teach people things and I'll tell
people now when I look back and say you
know what you can't teach somebody
nothing you ain't been through nothing
that's real you know what I mean I've
been through a lot and
um Vlad even did a poll when it came to
relationship advice and um what's the
gentleman who passed away
Uh Kevin Samuels
um he had like 90 something and I was
like 80 on relation advice I was right
number two on relation advice right
after Kevin Samuels so I thought that
was cool you know that was a respect
because Kevin Samuels was good oh Kevin
he dropped some yeah
he was honest and I used to always say I
wanted to give him the game
on yeah you could be brutal to women
You Gotta Give Them gain on what's the
solution you can't just [__] on them
with no solution give them a solution
right and then just move on right right
so you know I'm gonna talk about you but
you're gonna listen to me but here's the
solution here's the solution right and
that's where I that's my style yeah I
give the solution on what you should do
well obviously you are unmarried correct
yes you are a single man yes absolutely
um
what was the closest you had like for
you like because me and me and James are
obviously a new semi-new marriages he
just got married I just got married
we have yeah it's okay in general though
like uh you know I do I do feel like
there's a lot of different perspectives
on monogamy marriage all of that for you
let's say hypothetically somebody is
going through a rough patch in their
relationship
are you the kind of guy that believes in
like counseling or anything like that or
like like what would be some advice you
would give a couple who might not
necessarily be seeing eye to eye at the
moment yeah
get the [__] out that's a good question
see because
me I'll get rid of you okay me you me
all right you gotta go no problem yeah
you got to go now it might hurt because
I might like you right but what I would
see is what type of [__] you was
[__] with before you met me
see because every man has a
responsibility to to make a woman better
100 by the time she meet the [__] she
really supposed to be with so when I
[__] with certain women I'm like what
[__] [__] with you
see most [__] wanted to [__] you but
nobody wanted to give you gain nobody
wanted to teach you how to move right
when you roll with certain [__] see I
roll a certain way a female got to be a
certain way when you roll with me you
can't be all that back and forth you you
move with dignity and respect because
that's how I look at myself and you all
over the place you get you loud
you're causing confusion you petty maybe
right you can't rock with me any ounce
of pettiness your ass gotta go gots to
go immediately go immediately and no
matter how much you like a woman may
have done it deeply in love yeah man
I've done it I've been with some bad
[__] but you got to say to yourself I
I love you sister but I love me more you
know and that's why I teach people you
gotta love yourself more and
um men who are in relationships it all
depends on who you are
some [__] ain't got games some [__]
Ain't when I say games see most people
think game is just a magical way of
pulling the [__] right you know what
I'm saying oh you got game not [__] I
ain't got game I'm a [__] who speak
through it's like like philosophy right
you know every man should have a um um
what are your intentions right and and
when you meet the one you gotta look at
it what what's your what's my intentions
with the sister and if you're feeling a
break it down and break down your
Constitution so he says to I rock with
you so he we're gonna make a
constitution between you and I and it's
based on our understanding on how we're
gonna move with each other right
sometimes that's gonna go over some
women heads yeah right they're not the
[__] you mean the Constitution you know
do you think the the traditional
relationships the walls are kind of
breaking right now like back in the day
you had a relationship you had the man
bring the money home you have the woman
keep the house it's all [__] up now
fam do you think it's worse it's worse
now it's all [__] up all over the
world like you really gotta find
somebody that was raised a certain way
see because what men and women don't do
you I might like you but what is your
mother and your father's like what is
your friends you roll with because once
you start dating that person you got to
deal with all the other boys
you know
people don't think about that you
because you just like that person yeah I
think too like women nowadays if you're
pretty
all you are is
the willingness to show yourself on only
fans away for making six figures a year
these days yeah and like that kind of
like low like that was never the case
yeah you gotta look at
most men and women don't look long term
correct
see if you look at a woman you gotta
look 20 years from now actually yeah
with this woman it's her character
positive enough to take care of me if I
get ill right
okay she don't have no money
but do I make her an asset
but if I make an asset but I ain't [__]
I'm gonna be still [__] around I make
her rich and then she leave me and see
so many variables and I think I said on
the show before dating is like a Rubik's
Cube you kind of hope all the colors fit
because everything is different is that
why you're still single I'm single
because I find most women to be Petty
and I can't deal with it yo yeah yeah
that's that's probably one of those
traits that'll be hard to yeah listen to
me I cannot
deal with pettiness it's that serious to
me because I told you I'm happy I love
life yeah you're not gonna [__] them if
I'm gonna introduce you into my life you
gotta add to it if you're removing me
from any piece of Happiness right
because I think that's something we say
I said that men had to have 25 000 to be
in the relationship right and Everywhere
I Go people always ask me like TK we
ain't got that kind of money not that
much money respectfully let me explain
to you what I and I told this guy going
through the airport he asked me this
this other day
see my philosophy is really for the
young kids them kids 14 15 loving me
because them young boys like yo I rock
with you because I want to understand
stack your money it's like going to
college or buying your first house the
25 000 because they thought I meant give
the female 25 000. the 25 000 is for you
because when you got little change your
choice in holes is different you got a
little change you move through
differently most men [__] with a girl
because she dropped dead gorgeous
that's true but don't bring nothing to
the table yeah see because ads don't pay
the bills I mean
ass don't pay the bills I mean let
unless you got a girl doing only fans or
whatever I'm sure there's a few of them
going yeah for sure yeah but even if you
have the money what's your character and
I was gonna say that there's there's a
there's a takeaway in other avenues if
the ass is paying the bills it's a cat
or your character
um one time I was talking about women
using too much profanity yeah they're
getting upset now I know no man
but thinks that's hot that'll bring his
girl around his grandparents around his
mother and a girl every other world is
using profanity now to the ladies
listening nobody here is trying to tell
you what to do what I'm saying is I'm
not saying you shouldn't curse
I'm saying curse when you're really
upset when it means something because I
look at women as being the most
beautiful women on the planet and you
never know who's watching you right and
there's another girl watching the way
you move through life
whether you know it or not and if you
use a profoundly you act in a fool you
really God in her if she see you doing
it because of cool but if you say move a
certain way that girl gonna move
straight away so all women have to be
um responsible for each other because
when women move a certain way and move
with dignity move a class it's domino
effect other women want to be that way
yep you know and that's important to me
um
how do you make a one okay you said to
my earlier let's say there's a beautiful
girl but she doesn't have anything
in terms of
career-wise monetarily but you said make
her an asset because if you really like
someone you tell the female look I rock
with you but you gotta listen to me
so I'm gonna put you through school I
think you should get into nursing if
you've got to change I'm gonna pay for
you to go to school or get a nurse at
um I see you like to do nails well let
me see your character first you know
over the next couple years because what
men do we get so excited about a fine
female
[Music]
two months later you find out the
character is horrible as a person she
finds
a bit your character is [__] with me and
these [__] is one up they do so much
sometimes they want to want to hurt the
girl they want to kill them because of
their bad their bad decisions early yeah
because I'm they mad at themselves yeah
yeah you didn't know who you signed up
for it you moved too quick you moved too
quick yeah and you really have to take
your time and I tell men all the time
believe it or not the girl you meet that
day wait 30 days
or longer before you [__] her listen to
when you're talking on the phone hear
how she's talking to different people in
the background and she got kids and she
put up on God damn this thing I told you
put the [__] you heard me listen to
when she talk is a alarm detector going
off so she was too lazy to change the
battery
[Music]
like you got to pay attention no you
hear that and then every time you call
still going on yeah and then a person
actually said oh that's been going on
for a few months and then your mind you
like that's not the girl I want to be
with right it's these small little
things
that could tell you about a person if
you that lazy that you're not gonna
change the smoke detector battery
this is something [__] up about you
duh
yeah
go out with a woman and you see her car
and she got a lot of [__] in her vehicle
her whole car is dirty I tell women no
time whether it's a [__] up car clean
a nice car the inside better be nice
it's a representation of you that's how
I look at
like feet and Nails yes I'm like if your
feet aren't yes if you got [__] up
feet or your hands don't look like you
take care of them like what's that say
about how you take care of your feminine
and like I said and if you get a girl
who listens you like her she you're
gonna put it through school because
you're protecting yourself because when
you get older you know you might get ill
yeah is that person gonna wipe your ass
if you get sick you haven't found that
person yet I think I found a couple
people but they still was petty and
that's one thing
so what I do in life Define petty to you
give me like a situation that you're
just like like a few example I was
dating the girl okay um
one thing about me I'm very respectful
okay I'm a gentleman right and because I
travel so much I give you my itinerary
on how I move because if not for one
moment
I want you to worry about what I'm doing
as a man out of respect disrespected in
this ultimate respect right I'm Gonna
Give You ultimate respect because I want
your mind to be at peace yes I want your
[__] to be right with me I don't want
arguments that's how much I appreciate
peace of mind so me and this person was
doing this for about three four weeks
and then three days
[__] happened she wasn't picking up
the phone right well she picked to find
the phone up right and then when I
finally talked to her she thought that
the [__] was okay I said you got me
[__] up and I liked her and I thought
I can give her another opportunity I
couldn't do it because in my mind see I
have the ability to meet somebody else
every day
so
um
could you justify speed you gotta fall
in line or get online because I'm like
next yeah there's not a problem with
that I feel like people get upset at
other people's preferences you know like
if that's your preference I don't have
time to I'm not a therapist I'm not
trying to figure you out right when
people meet a relationship is not
supposed to be about arguments let's be
happy and you if that person's not
making you happy you shouldn't be with
that person if you're arguing over
stupid [__] right I'm talking about
stupid [__] right ain't nobody got time
for that [__] yo
you know when I hear you young guys
getting married it's phenomenal to me
right right because what you met maybe
30 women in your life maybe I'm just
gonna put that up maybe listen buddy uh
30. like that's insane to me all due
respect to
I had I've had quite a uh I've had quite
a run okay so but so that's good so you
know the girl that you with is the girl
you're supposed to be with yeah I
married her when I was 31 and I would
say from about 17 to
29. okay that's good I was and that's
what I want to hear taking down strange
and a right very uh yeah very large and
all those and believe it or not all
those experiences made you choose her
yeah for sure and then I also had like a
crazy baby mama situation right most
toxic wild ass [__] of all time yes you
see what I'm saying everything remember
I said earlier yeah everything that you
experience your flight yeah you met her
all those things you went to said to you
this the one that's the one for sure for
sure yeah when I met my wife
because me and her were friends first so
I kind of like got to know her like all
the stuff you're saying like I kind of
already had I knew a lot of that stuff
how she's built her character you know
very good blue I'm glad you understood
what I was saying because that's so
important if you could find that yeah
you got a winner that's fair what do you
feel because I feel like
recently I mean again you move in your
own
Stratosphere but when we see guys like
uh Chappelle or
you know I saw Louis C.K they were mad
at some some stuff yeah from a Louis CK
set where he was just working out it
wasn't even supposed to get out there
do you feel like
because
comedy I feel like is on purpose we're
supposed I feel like I want to kind of
be like offended when I go to a comedy
show but like in terms of like some of
these bigger comedians
these cancellation campaigns it feels
like especially with Dave man
um what are your thoughts like if you
were to
talk to a comedian like Dave or Louis
C.K or these guys like like is that
something to even worry about when
you're at that level or do you just kind
of do you you just do you those guys are
on a whole nother level I watch their
careers grow and
um it's just fascinating to see all this
because like I said when I started this
with Michael Williams and Robin Harris
back in 1985. wow these guys wasn't
around right so to see them do their
thing to see how this this entertainment
thing works and like I said in the last
10 years the world has changed right the
world's changed like what we knew as
entertainment
for the last 30 years
throw it all out the window yeah because
it doesn't apply like whoever thinks the
Kardashians would be as rich as they are
it's crazy man you understand what I'm
saying and his Fame and it's famous as
they are as famous as they are in the
world change so the thing in
entertainment I would tell people is
um do your best
make everybody your associate because
you never know who gonna blow right
right like I keep your Bridges open
don't keep your Bridges open right you
know I think that's what you got to do
and then you can't worry about the um
that he say she says no give an example
like when I had a problem with uh Eddie
Murphy and Charlie Murphy back in the
day yeah and people felt like oh TK got
black ball used to say the stupid [__]
but nobody blackballed me I'm still
working we just have social media to
show you what I was doing yeah I never
have missed a beat right never Mr B but
those experiences in life
um
as embarrassing as it is today I'm
actually glad I also went through it
because
um like I said I had a time when I was
really that [__] so people know
that [__] you don't really want to
cross because
t to the [__] get you right but
not knowing at the same time at 62 I'm
really on the spiritual
journey I don't know I'm not what was
the ish uh the origin of your issues
with Eddie and Charlie well it wasn't an
issue something that I just wanted to
mention it doesn't want to go because
it's been talked about for over 40 years
it happened in 1982 and it's a thing
that I really like to not really discuss
too much yeah you've discussed it yeah
my thing my thing with anything I've
ever done
in life
um
I was supposed to go through it right
and as a man you stand up to it you
apologize if these people still around
if they accepted accepted they don't
they don't you know because everybody
know I'm a man like I move a certain way
I want to know do you have any advice
man because we've been losing uh a lot
of artists at a high rate now obviously
when you were coming up pop died biggie
died yes but nowadays it feels like
every year we're losing or every other
month yeah five to ten guys are done I
mean yeah you know the takeoff situation
was super tragic yeah because you felt
like a freak accident You Gotta Know Who
You Are
what I mean by I got to know who you are
you can't always keep it real you got to
know sometimes you're better than people
right
because if you feel like you better
people you're gonna say I'm not going on
that block I'm not going into that
situation because I'm successful now I
gotta move differently because
especially when you're black you're a
Target 100 and that young man was
gambling in a club
right if you want a gamble [__] let's
go to the casino let's do this [__]
officially right like you're a
Millionaire right you're a millionaire
let's go to the casino and gamble you
ain't gotta keep it real with your
homies right that something can go left
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie that's
right baby Super Bowl is coming well you
know in a month or so we got the
playoffs right now you could get those
future bets in on who you think out of
this uh barrage of teams that made it to
the playoffs is going to win the Super
Bowl you could bet player props we can
go NBA action on them so much ways to
make money with all the sports going on
and you could do it all at my bookie
right now if you go to my bookie and you
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
you know what's dub about my bookie not
only can you bet on your favorite sports
but you could also get a little
Blackjack going little slot machines in
that thing yummy a little loud little
roulette yeah me so much ways to get
paid on my bookie the most important
thing is though if you sign up and you
use the promo code bootleg at my bookie
go to my bookie my bookie my bookie my
bookie use the promo code bootleg and
they're gonna match your first deposit
up to one thousand dollars right [__]
now
listen I'm a degenerate but I'm pretty
good at this
I've been using my bookie for like 10
years all right very trusted they're the
best trust me they are the [__] best
wherever you're at if you're watching
this you can sign up for my bookie
account one more time that's my book you
use the promo code bootleg and they will
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars free [__] money
let's get to it all right boys back to
the interview
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the Bluetooth
right to your [__] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[__] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [__] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[__] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [__]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not going to perform
it's not it's not going to perform how
you'd like it to but you know how it
will perform if you're on that [__]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [__] Luka
donkicch 61 Point [__] performance on
that [__] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview you got to be more calculated
about the situations you expose yourself
to yes if you have a lot more to lose
yes they should have been in a casino
I'm doing it professionally yeah with
[__] around them in bottles and [__]
right security everywhere everywhere you
protect it I do feel like sometimes that
is kind of like the conundrum of hip-hop
because we look at artists and we want
them to keep it real yeah and we want
them to be about what they're rapping
about but at a certain point in time
it's counterproductive to them as people
yeah you gotta know like once you make
it in your mouth you know you change you
should have you changed she was like oh
you changed you supposed to yeah see
everybody you meet in your life
once you start growing up you you still
could be their friend I just can't rock
with you the way because my life is
growing no disrespect to you I've grown
that's what life's about you should be
happy that I'm growing I'm not gonna
[__] on you right right I'm just I'm
taking off and I want to see everything
this world has to offer yeah you're
still gonna be my friend right but I
want to meet more people yeah I want to
meet everybody before I leave experience
more things yeah like people I always
tell people if you die where you're born
you ain't you never did nothing
that's some real [__] that's a good one
right there yeah I think you should you
should be buried somewhere else
now talking about some people are famous
they get they fly back home
but this is for the life itself
kids who grow up in certain cities and
they move that's that's a success that
you can move from where you grew to
someone else make it and then get buried
in a different place I think that's so
important and we've seen a lot of these
guys die on the block or this like
streets yeah because everybody's in the
bed
everybody got the mindset of the hood
[__] and the goal is to get the bag
it don't have to be a big bag as long as
you pay your bill as long as you pay
your cable you could you could feed
everybody right and find ways to make
money because
if you don't read about what's going on
with the government if you don't read um
how the world has changed with coding
right how you walking around here with
no llc's you walking around here with no
eins and I always tell people how this
[__] is so free it's right there in
front of you and I always put people on
ink file you know
um.com you you fill out the application
and they send you a free LLC in three
weeks then when you get your free LLC
um get that LLC and you go to the um IRS
website and you put that information on
the IRS website and they send you a free
Ein
um
this the stuff that I teach people to do
that's the type of yeah do you let me
ask you this because you're you're very
financially uh
you I think that your financial literacy
is at a high level do you
how do you like do you leverage credit
cards do you use credit cards or are you
yeah using my credit cards all the time
I I don't worry about interest rates I
have people bring my interest rates on
their credit card I don't give a [__]
about this [__] I'll just be I just pay
it pay it off I just pay it I've used it
paid the [__] I pay it off
before the end of the month yeah if I
spend 10 15
000 that [__] is paid by Monday that's
smart and then you get all the free
points yeah I'm not worried I'm not
worrying about the people who are
worried about the interest rate or the
people who are living beyond their means
yes you're supposed to use the credit
card as a tool yeah to build your credit
to get free perks and all that and then
pay that [__] off but my credit is in
the high I think I'm almost high 800s
[__] damn 790. yeah and I haven't always
been like 103. yeah and I haven't always
been like that my credit was [__] up
at one time you know I remember when I
was young I was trying to get [__] to
put they name put a car in their names
and all that type of [__] I was gonna
pay the bill and all that but I see how
the world worked out now and I ain't
worried about that but
um credit is good credit is important to
all men you know like I think that's
something important too that when you
get with a woman y'all talk about how we
can help each other get our credit
together yeah right
um now it wasn't like that when I was
growing up now you could use your
apartment
on your credit helps your credit score I
didn't know that you didn't know yeah
yeah your apartment your apartment now
if you put a report it'll help boost
your credit there's a there's a credit
card
billt that they just dropped this year
that's
you could uh
what is it it it's it's the one that you
can pay your rent on the credit card
so it it's Bilt right the build credit
card that's good so it's like it's like
this new credit card and it allows you
so what what you do is you set it up
with them and then they pay your rent
for they'll send a check to your
landlord every month but it goes on your
credit so you can pay it off obviously
but it goes towards getting you rewards
[__] hotel awesome but now you gotta
think there's a fee on that correct I
don't know I don't actually know it's a
free card there's no monthly there's no
yeah so long as American Express they
got like 500 yeah yeah yeah yeah but
that's if you got the the big call you
got the big guy yeah I got the big boy
yeah he knows yeah I got the big boy so
um but that's good to know I'm gonna put
that in my stand up BLT b-i-l-t b-i-l-t
built b-i-l-t right in the name if it's
BLT annual fees on the amex's yes it's a
business card
okay good I'm gonna let my tax lady know
because I don't think I've ever wrote
that at all and I spent a lot of money I
need to tell her that [__] absolutely
yeah what would be your advice for
somebody who is James Andre Jefferson Jr
this guy's huge on Tick Tock yes I know
he was telling me he's got I mean the
rock DMS him every other day this guy's
very successful in his Lane but he wants
to actually
start doing actual stand-up comedy
because would you say James you're
you're an internet comedian so pretty
much I started getting on stage when I
was 13. right and then I seen the wave
when I was like 1980 okay so online is
popping right made a stupid mistake I
stopped doing stand-ups going on online
so now I'm mainly online now I'm getting
back I'm doing open mics and stuff right
I told you about my agency they want to
start get a tour going everything I'm
just trying to get my [__] back together
right so what advice would you have you
got to stay on stage yeah so there's no
magical thing you can do okay I put the
work in you got to put the work in and
there's no shortage of open mics here
yeah there's there's there's no secret
cut there there's no shortcut you gotta
you gotta write you gotta um go hit that
stage and you gotta hit it yo you got to
be on stage at least when I was coming
up I was on stage at least
seven times a week I could do a show
then get in the car Zoom way across town
to go do a show there it was crazy you
know it was crazy but um I laughed now
I'm sitting here with you guys and I'm
sitting in places all over the world
because I was patient
to understand
um there was gonna be a moment for me
and it's still getting better I was
telling me and James always talk about
doing open mics and I have a joke I have
the beginning of a joke but I don't know
how to it's that we're all a certain
percentage of gay
I'm listening
do you watch lesbian porn no
do you like
you gotta you savings you like dick in
your porn
anyway
that's clever you don't like a small
dick in airport right yeah that's clever
but okay if you're doing it looking that
way I have I I have what you call Dick
Envy yeah I mean it did in there because
I like I got a nice dick me too and I
wish I had three extra inches everybody
does like no then you know that me like
and I could sling this tomorrow right
but sometimes when I see uh I'm envious
of [__] with bigger dicks my thing is
is like I don't want to watch a porno
where the dude's got a smaller dick than
me because I'd be like it makes sense
when you look at it it doesn't mean
you're gay don't mean you're fruity
maybe one percent you know it don't
matter no that's what I was trying to
tell maybe two percent gay because it
okay so you're telling me I don't think
it's gay it's not gay but it's it's it's
gay-ish no no no no it's still not even
gays it's understanding sex okay see
there's certain things you just have to
understand like sex is supposed to be
nasty yeah you looking it's not gay you
just see somebody doing work and you say
okay that's cool and you got digging I
wish I wish I can [__] like that decent
premise for a joke though yes okay yo
it's a great it's a great setup you know
just lay it out I just want to go to an
open mic and get that one off so it's
just like this
um and I ask you this question yeah is
Ash cheeks one word or do I have to
spread them apart
[Laughter]
I like that
if I see a thumbnail right and I click
on it and I open it and it's like it's
like an inadequate dude or it's some
lesbian it motivates you if you see it
motivates me it motivates you you see a
[__] throwing down you're like [__]
[__] this [__] you know what I'm saying
I'm better than this [__] [__]
that [__] you know what I'm saying
y'all that [__] did what [__] oh [__]
you ain't got [__] on me and then it
helps mentally because when you [__]
the girl you could say you know I'm
pretend my dick is that big even though
I got a little dick I mean I'm a [__]
the way this [__] was [__] that girl
in the video and even though my dick is
little I got the word I got The Verge
yeah [__] take this big dick even
though she laughed
but in your mind because we all
get caught up in the visual we are all
influenced yeah music influence us porn
influence commercials everything
influencers on what we wear
colognes and a whale [__] [__] a woman
influence you as well because you want
to be better than what you are watching
and porn can also negatively influence
you yeah if you watch too much you get
wrapped up in it you could you it can be
I watch porn now
maybe five times a year I'm that busy
what's that [__] that's a great race
yeah see but my my even my sex life is
not used to being my sex like when I was
running I swear I was 99 now
my sex life is not even past two
it's a it's probably a zero nine nine
are we are we uh doing the Viagra no no
not yet not yet not yet well you know
I'd like to introduce this is a great
opportunity to talk about go to
bluetooth.com right now
same active ingredient okay yeah and the
ritual form delivered to your door
discreetly and let me explain to you why
I won't I here's the promo code bootlegs
I had a couple doctors who died taking
Cialis in Viagra died heart attacks have
you ever done a honey pack no that's
perfect right there honey packs yeah
them shits I've done I've I've
recreationally tried Viagra okay okay
was it any better you saw a difference
but the difference is much better with
Bluetooth but there's there's 23 year
olds using that [__] yeah yeah see I I
did an interview wake up in the morning
and you're [__] I had I did an
interview
with his man who's a doctor and he was
saying that young kids you guys age yeah
have erectile dysfunction who I don't
see I don't have dysfunction no no no
I'm just saying in general yeah right
it's a thing and because of health
because they're not taking themselves
you know with the lean with the smoking
no and they're not working out right
you're destroying your body my walk yeah
because you walk like you're 60
something years old
[Applause]
you should be embarrassed
[Music]
you should be embarrassed you're walking
like you almost 70 years old because
I've been working out so hard since
2016. I'm gonna put you up on game I'm
gonna share this with you it's because
he eats like [__] like where we at right
now yeah he's like I can tell you he's
[__] up now watch this I'm about to
tell you
where you at right now this area is
beautiful right
walk
maybe 20 blocks down
and 20 bucks back every day
one you're gonna work that's gonna get
your heart right right it also gives you
time to think about your material that
you're going to do just walk and look at
different things therapeutic you'll be
dodging a lot of homeless [__] down
people when you start seeing certain
things like the Matrix the materials
start coming to
that's what you got to do see when you
when you become a certain comedian
things
right you'd be surprised
when God walk every day every day you
take an hour from here hmm to go walk I
don't know how fast you walk but 20
blocks an hour crazy no no no that's a
Sprint yeah
just walk until you get a nice Sweat
Right
do that every day I promise you on my
life it'll change your life my main
thing has been my diet because I do eat
like [__] you're like DJ Khaled and Rick
Ross y'all have been the same way for so
long yeah this is true this is true
here's here's the advice on eating
foot
in your body was beneficial if it
doesn't benefit you while you're eating
it so I I just started this year a salad
today so yeah salad for lunch yeah we
gotta hope it's not too late I hope it's
because sometimes you can start to like
health is based on starting young right
and going your whole life sometimes you
kids start to late right so the walking
see the most important exercise the
people I see lifting and all that that's
not the most important muscle your heart
is
so you want to get your heart that's why
you got to walk and then you got to feed
yourself you gotta love love yourself to
the point that you just won't put
anything in your body you gotta drink
your water there's people who don't
drink [__] water
right and they them research on how
important what it is for your body to
keep you alive I drink a lot of water I
drink like uh here's one as you get
older and tell you why you have to drink
water
one you should drink a bottle of water
before you go to bed at night because it
prevents heart attack and strokes I
didn't know that that's what water does
to you the body is at its weakest point
between
um four and six o'clock in the morning
that's where most people die and they
sleep between four and six wow because
your body's that's for some reason is
the weakest point of your body I'm not
saying water is going to actually stop
it but I've also done my research water
prevents heart attacks and strokes then
you want to drink a glass of water
before you do anything you say before
you start your day and that wakes up
your organs in your body I've read that
yeah I read that and most people do the
wrong thing when they eat in the morning
you're not supposed to eat in the
morning right no you're supposed to eat
but you put the wrong things you put
eggs and bacon in your body coffee so
you're not supposed to eat that after
12. in the morning supposed to be water
and fruit
um
that's what you're supposed to eat in
the morning that makes sense I'm gonna
start that yeah starting tomorrow water
and fruit every morning and then between
12 and three you have eat a little
something and then you can eat a little
something around five and then the rest
of the night if you're hungry you gotta
have apples you know pineapples because
um the world has set us up to make us
think
that you're supposed to have all these
other medications but pineapples
strawberries cherries is your medicine
for life
pineapples do something I can't remember
pineapples do something for your eyes
and all these all these fruits do
something to keep you healthy same thing
for women too for sure yeah
yes yes yes yes it's so important that
everybody this is what we talk about
we're just not talking about men
everybody should get their checkups to
be on this planet a long time
yeah I've I saw that uh somebody was
just saying on YouTube that like if a
woman has a bad diet it's hard for
her situation to be the best the vagina
that's smelling yeah yeah it can smell
or you could it may not be that moist
and wet see because that's the that's a
terrible that's also a bad thing when
you know what good [__] is true see
because you can love the woman
we just had this remember we were just
talking about this when we were
recording the show earlier would you
rather oh be with because we do a radio
show every day yeah so it's [__] up
question but so the question is would
you rather be with someone who you love
who everything with the sex
is just whatever isn't that something or
would you rather be with the person
who's toxic Petty pain in the ass but
the sex is crazy he knows crazy the
happiness is because you're
in the moment at that time in the moment
like I like this person
even though she can't [__] it because I
just got out of that right situation
this is a human mind now you're with
this girl
drive me [__] crazy but you [__] me
like a guy right but I like
because Too Short said it best
you're never gonna find everything you
want in one person
if you find that person marry them you
shout out to my wife yeah if you could
find if you can find that person that
got everything you want just do it you
wrap it up I feel you you won I mean
that you won me
it's the petty thing that's holding you
back yeah I'm telling you with me I'm
62. I'm gonna ride this [__] out [__]
you know
it is
y'all it's too late for me to go through
[__] in my life
that's fair because we got a lot of yeah
I mean yeah no I hope I get 30 more
Summers out this bit you might get 30 or
40. yeah you know I hope I can get 30 30
more Summers that'll put me at it what
was the Madonna tour like did you have a
relationship with her were you guys
I know they love Beyonce and everybody
I've seen ain't nobody called in Madonna
really ain't nobody dominating The Hive
life live ain't nobody colder Madonna
Beyonce live show oh there's no doubt
about it and I love Beyonce and I know
people are gonna hit hit me over there
I'm rolling out the scene don't get me
but remember lazy dummy before y'all
start tripping and before they edit this
I'm gonna share something with you
every generation has their Superstar 100
back when I was growing up we had
Michael Jordan you guys got LeBron right
back in my day it was um Tupac and
Biggie now y'all got Drake and young boy
right right everybody has a generation
and we shouldn't really compare it and
one I'm gonna apologize for even
comparing Madonna right to Beyonce
because that was a different different
yeah different area and we shouldn't do
that they should never compare Michael
Jordan to LeBron I think especially with
sports I agree especially with sports
everybody had they era that's what they
should talk about you should know who's
the best now during the era that
[__] was the man because when I
get old and grow up ain't nobody gonna
tell me Kendrick better and nobody's
gonna be better than Kendrick right so
it is what it is right and that's every
generation's gonna have they go right
yeah
you guys got Kevin Hart right you know
what I'm saying in a sense but there's
more comics now there's more comics now
than it was when I was growing up I love
Kevin Hart yeah when I was growing we
had like nine comedians right now it's
like damn now there's a million it's a
million [__] out there now
how do we feel about Kevin Hart James I
love Kevin Hart I like um did you like
his stand-up you dropped during the
pandemic is that the one he did in the
living room yeah
wasn't great
that was it was good but it was it was
missing something you know what I like
about I love her I like his work ethic
love is working but I'm gonna tell you
we got like really big specials right
like eight nine I mean he's a beast he's
a beer let me tell you work ethic is
inspired let me tell you what I really
like that [__] on them chase
commercials thank you on Chase Bank
[__] he the man
he almost make me want to go get that
[__] car yeah let me break it
down he's I said man out of all the
comedians I've seen in the world
he really got this commercial [__] down
and he's just very likable he's very
likable we had a conversation off the
air kind of about a different comedian I
don't know we won't say his name but
like somebody who's
Kevin Hart's way better than this guy at
standing
amazing personally I think he's a little
overrated but I think he's great yeah
he's good right but but there was
another comedian who's much smaller
right maybe from the same city
um who
is great at being a like likable I guess
okay as opposed to you know what I mean
so I think Kevin Hart checks all the
boxes yes yes at a high level which is
why he's probably the big like when you
compare him to Eddie Murphy that's fair
because Kevin Hart's doing Arenas yeah
you know what I mean yes yes he's the I
think he's is it safe to say he's the
biggest comedian yeah
yeah he's the most tickets yeah yeah no
one's selling more tickets than him
right and like he's been past that like
and in life
Joe Coy's on the way though yeah and in
life I'd say to people life's not fair
get used to it I think I'm the best
[__] standard comedian that ever
touched a mic right A lot of people
don't know me but once you see me it's
different [__] once you see me I love
that feeling why haven't you done the
online special to where people can go
and watch I just drop one on YouTube or
something like 60 Minute just heater
because I think it'd do great man I
never thought about that
because I do think that you are kind of
like the underground rapper right you
gotta catch TK when he's in your city
you're gonna see him live right then
you'll get it right but then if I go
tell
like if I go tell Jay man I just saw
this [__] TK Kirkland I feel
like I should be able to go on your
YouTube channel and see an hour yeah I
wanna I think that's something I got to
do I think I'm gonna do more as a legacy
thing too yeah because they're going to
do more on you because I think we cut my
special up and put it on YouTube I'll
call you got to do the whole joint yeah
promote it do the whole rollout for it
right Joe Rogan like like it was an HBO
special
but it's all
you're the one controlling it yeah
matter of fact I'm gonna put it together
I'm gonna put a sponsored by you guys
you gotta do it even though I put up the
money yeah put up no money I'll put up
the money it'll do great dude yeah I'll
call my team we put something together I
think you should do that every two years
because like you said if you got 30 more
Summers in 40 years the way we go back
and watch
anything because I got three specials
out now but you should have way more I
should have more because you're [__]
TK Kirk yeah absolutely but we'll do
that and I think we need your comedy in
today's climate we get the interview
Clips we get that yes that shit's great
but we want to see you at work yeah I
like that and I always believe in
co-signing so I get you the co-sign and
let me tell you why what's my co-signing
mean okay hey we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at hardean that's right
Hardin Las Vegas the craziest dispensary
in the world the number one dispensary
in the United States let alone in Las
Vegas all right maybe you're hitting
Vegas with your friends your girlfriends
whatever maybe it's a bachelor party
whatever's going on you're going to go
watch the Raiders suck [__] whatever it
is make sure you pull up to Hardy in Las
Vegas tell them I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [__] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top-notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friend it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
ah see I sniff that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Harding merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview hey we got to stop
the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[__] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something they're Black
Friday sale if you're watching this
before Black Friday you might be
watching it after Black Friday but if
Black Friday hasn't came yet just like
Cyrus hasn't came yet it's been a while
he's on a drought guess what
oddsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
20 off plus whatever the [__] else is
going on with their black Friday sale
and let me tell you they got some new
licenses we got to talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [__] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [__] movie you know what
I mean
these are pretty fly Bubblicious yeah
that's right a little Bubblicious and
this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we got to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [__]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[__] [__] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [__] ethica or
some [__] ass [__] Nike socks
[__] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview
didn't know how this was gonna come into
play one day uh years ago in the 60s
when the Jackson 5 was discovered okay
very good it just didn't put the Jackson
5. he had a co-signer he started Ross oh
wow the album cover said Diana Ross
presents the Jackson 5. this is in 1968.
you guys was nowhere around watch what
I'm about to tell you man
says I go through life
and I see certain people who blew up
there's artists who blew up but then
when they had a co-sider it took him to
a whole nother level right and when Dr
Dre and Eminem signed 50 it was
different it was different than when 50
try to make it before he had to have no
cosine right yeah for sure
you need a co-signer sometimes to say
this motherfucker's official I think I
think everybody knows you're official I
think that you're so brilliant as a
stand-up comedian yes that I feel like
you got to put that you gotta you gotta
show the world that because at the end
of the day like you said right there's
people in London there's people there's
people in markets you're not going to go
to yes that want to see your stuff your
[__] but believe it or not they do they
have seen it okay I just mean in terms
of like no we're gonna do it yeah
Paul you want to put this [__] together
off the air what I want to do I want to
do the thing with the um the podcast
thing and then we'll get Freddie Gibbs
we'll get you on Joe Rogan yeah I would
love that
because he's been on there twice yeah I
didn't know
Joe follows me
he's a [__] community
no no once I do that this game is over
it's over when I do Joe Rogan listen to
me we said it here
TK Kirk is a rock star I agree I promise
you 100 I agree I already see you as a
rock stars man you are a rock star man
just the simple fact of your longevity
just that right there I'm truly like
it's so impressive 30.
38 years in the game and stay relevant
the entire time and see I think
comedians go up and down right
for us the whole time there was never no
dips
straight across and I don't um one of my
friends said it best he said TKA you
never
um wear your wealth not some people just
overdo it of course they do yeah as he
said you never like one day I was had a
little outfit on with the Louis Vuitton
[__] and it looked nice yeah but I
really don't care like I wear white tees
on purpose because I travel so much I
don't like iron and [__] in my my
shirt's got to come out the plastic bag
my underwear every day got to be brand
new like some people buy a lot of
jewelry I buy a lot of underwear I buy a
lot of white tees I like to smell good I
like to get my massages my facials and
[__] like I I invest in me right right
you know and what I teach people too
about
um
investing see investing is they got you
thinking that's what you should do and
that's for the to me the small man
because you want to be rich right so
let's take basketball players you know
[__] who's really rich and when you
think about the Bernie madoffs how they
ripped you off see ya
a huge financial firm you know you got
80 million they'll come to you
they'll come to you yeah oh I want to
invest your money
to take three to five percent of your
money that whatever happens they lose it
they still get their percentage but you
on lost but you you made it you invested
in you that's why you have 80 right now
you have that money yeah here's my point
you got that money why do you need more
sick of your mindset is greed you take
the chance to lose it but you have
invested in you your whole life and you
have enough to you got enough to live
off the rest of your life yeah you're
still being greedy so here's the
philosophy the Richer you are
the lower your means
but see people who have low means live
beyond their means
but in your mindset
see I don't care how big your houses
don't care how many rooms you have the
mattress is still going to be the same
size yeah
yeah that's real that's a real [__]
right there
and also if you have real wealth or you
are are doing well
what do you try like you don't have to I
feel like people who out outwardly try
to they're they're doing that for
everyone else they're doing that to try
to you have to be right because nobody
cares right I got everything right but
it's like you're not gonna wait like I
feel like you know a lot of that has to
do with just like today's culture I mean
that's always been the case people
wearing gold people wearing jewelry but
in terms of just like
it's like I don't gotta prove nothing to
you I'm married I got my money's in the
bank you want me to would you want me to
wear some designers so you could so I
could feel good around strangers or
people a lot of things to do is nice
vacations yeah that kind of [__] is
where you spend money that's where you
spend money you want to be in a nice
experience you want to enjoy your
champagne or whatever you do then you
come back home when you go back into the
real world but you ain't got a ride
around in the Rolls-Royce you ain't
gotta drive around that's the way you
could ask him I barely just bought it
like so listen I'm always paid off cars
live way below my means right yes I just
bought my first house with my wife I've
had bought a house in Vegas but yes we
just bought a house last year for like a
1.5 million right in Burbank but I just
finally bought a nice car because for
tax purposes six thousand pounds are
heavier people don't understand that so
I was like all right
I guess I'm either gonna write a check
to the IRS or I'm going to buy this
that's what I tell people when they talk
about uh how Floyd and other spend some
much money I said they do it not because
they they want to if they don't buy [__]
the government's gonna take it they
would rather write the check and buy 10
Escalades yep
then give all that money to the
government and get nothing in return
nothing to return so true and so that's
what you that's what you have to do do
you do that every year like around
October November I put it like this I
live underneath my means I mean in terms
of like when you know that tax bill is
going to hit does your CPA give you the
heads no what I do I'm smarter than all
of them what I do with me is I um I
write everything the [__] off
everything and I put people up on games
too see I donate a lot of clothes to
Goodwill and you know you get those
forms you can put your own numbers in
there I donate to Goodwill about 200
times a year oh wow and each time you
get a form every time you get a form so
by the end of the year I've given over
200 000 to get well oh [__] and that's
the tax write-off
that's a [__] bar my grandma put me
on on that long time I'm getting close
to my friends yeah no Goodwill because
they give you a receipt yeah don't they
send it like five minutes
I get somebody close to my friends [__]
them take it to the Goodwill in the
black make sure you get your receipt you
fill out your stuff you stack them all
year and then and send it to you
I'm on top of that and that's though
it's not illegal no you're donating I
love that that's smart make a note the
rock
yeah yeah hey you guys can get no more
free clothes yeah so my thing sorry
Cyrus I'm glad that we have built this
relationship but like I said and we're
hearing that all right we're gonna I'm
gonna bring my podcast over to you we
got to I want to change I want to change
don't get me wrong I own my own [__] and
what I like now
um as we move forward over the next 10
15 years I want to change the game a
little bit because
um I don't really think anybody could
out hustle me okay and I've been
cruising
um
for two years because
the way I move I move organically right
you gotta move organically I don't like
forcing nothing fair when I came in
today I felt the energy I think you're
the right person to do what we got to do
then you introduce me to Freddie not
knowing that inspired me because I see
that [__] yeah right and I never knew
that Nick was a fan yeah like that means
so much to me when people walk up and
say yo
give you the truth and I'm like wow
that's my [__] I'm more shocked that
I'm more shocked about them knowing me
than vice versa let me ask you this we
were talking off the air and I was like
yo your podcast is so great but you
should do it in video form yeah and
you're like well I'm never in the same
place I'm never insane so it's a little
hard yes it is to pull that off now I'd
like there's two things one
there is a podcast that's very
successful I think Tim Dylan's doing
about 250 Grand a month on his [__] and
he'll bring his producer on the road
with him and sometimes they'll shoot in
a hotel room that's that's one thing but
two I think if you
took three to six months off from the
road
and invested in the podcast you might
make five or six times more than you can
make on the road it's not about money to
me okay that's fair I was gonna say it
a matter of
you're you're still very passionate and
in love with being on stage and touching
the people yes and and it's not about
money to me um it never has been but
eventually that could be the that's
gotta I think you've developed that out
because maybe maybe you hit 68 69 and
you're like you know what man I need to
no what we're going to do is we're going
to do what we talked about right and
we're gonna let the um life deal the
cards that's fair and that's the way you
got to do instead of planning we see
where this takes us right yeah that's
fair and then we start doing certain
things and maybe
um if I get the energy maybe I come here
once a month yeah to do something with
you guys right we taper tker podcast we
because I don't just do celebrities
right I do people walking down the
street I think that's right I also think
that that's so uh Theo Von do you know
Theo van is the name sounds familiar so
he's a comedian
um he's got a hilarious podcast but
he'll interview celebrities yeah it's in
other times he'll have like just a
random a female a plumber or something
like that yeah or he'll have a more tit
like he literally has had a mortician on
the on the podcast and it's just
hilarious because it's like a comedian
talking to somebody right dude that him
is a mortician in Nashville and that's
why that kind of [__] is fun I talked to
just the average person like if you just
like found like a [__] retired
prostitute yes or some [__] like that
right right I deal with all those type
of things and that's what I like and the
reason why I did that because I really
hate asking people I always never wanted
to be the dude to ask another celebrity
to do something right because there's
too many letdowns that's true oh I'm
gonna be there at 11 then the day before
they got to cancel that's true or
something comes up right and I hate
asking [__] I've always been
that dude I ain't asking nobody for [__]
I just always been that guy I go out
there and get it and like I said when we
talked earlier about the gossip about
the 25
000 and I'll tell this to any man say
ain't nothing
expensive
you just gotta work harder 100 yeah and
you're not the same when you're feeling
broke yeah ain't nothing expensive you
just gotta work hard if I tell you to
have 25
000 in your account
before you start [__] [__] You Gotta
Go Get It Go Get It see if you got that
ambition you gotta you got to go get it
and that's what and I always tell men
too
if you really love the girl that you
watch this now you know
I say you really love her
I said you really think you love her I
said look at your girl right now look at
her and ask her one for ten thousand
dollars
I said you know why you ain't looking at
it because you know she ain't got it so
my philosophy is if I can't use you
you're useless
[__] I'm gonna have you around for just
to look at all [__] day now
here's the and here's the flip side if I
can't depend on you if [__] hits the fan
right and here's the flip side I don't
need the money
I'm gonna make sure you got it
just like you said I mean [__] I gotta I
got arrested and I had to call my girl
to pull together a serious amount of
money and she did it and she did it
showed up cash ready to go hey that's
what the [__] I mean yeah
that's so important super important even
though
you don't want to live that kind of life
or whatever but things happen yeah it
was a situation that was unforeseen and
you know yeah I got out you know yeah
and that's a powerful word what you said
it's a thing called unforeseen
occurrences and that and you gotta
account for that when you choose your
partner or you choose the people and
that's what I want men and women to
think about when they meet
um
because they don't think that way and
that's my new moment I'm starting to
write my book that's what I'm working on
and it'll be out probably a year maybe
two is called the manual oh I love it I
was gonna say it should be called TK's
life rules the man it's called the
manual I like that a lot actually yeah
it's the man it's gonna be the new Bible
and I'm putting everything in like the
things we're talking about yeah I mean
for people who don't know the last
interview pretty much if you're [__]
a girl
and you don't got 25 Grand what happens
if she gets pregnant exactly unforeseen
nobody thinks about that sir then you
don't even got the [__] money to take
care of that [__] you ain't got the
[__] money or I hear [__] say oh oh
they want her to get rid of the baby but
when you put your penis gentleman in a
woman and you nutted her that's on you
[__] what the [__] you think was gonna
happen yeah
if you feel like either you go buy that
[__] plan b or dude get the plan B I
had sex with a woman nothing in there
and I went right to the store and got we
was eating dinner
open the package and I slid that
[__] over it and you know and I
had a little drink and and I helped with
the drink
are you staring too and she said I'm not
gonna take another plan B and I stop
[__] her oh yeah okay well that was
the last time I [__] well that's good
to know yeah
that's the last time I [__] up but
those things are so important and I'm
glad that we covered all the things from
the um
sexual assault thing yeah to understand
who you should date as you move forward
and if you listen to what we just said
ladies and gentlemen it I hope you
choose your partner 100 instead of just
being with someone because that's being
I got a man yeah I got a woman that you
you you got to balance it out yeah
there's a lot of people who sell value
is very dependent on being in a
relationship for some reason I know a
lot of people like a lot of people are
like yes
they have to be in a relationship you
gotta get a hobby you gotta love
yourself so much you gotta go bowling
gotta go hiking you gotta have these
things about you
that aren't identifiable with your
Association to each other and you gotta
learn how to live by yourself yeah
everybody should live by themselves
first before they get into moving in
with a woman I think if I
if I got married
that woman will have to live in her own
house
[Laughter]
not another room a whole another house
you love life now you like having your
own yeah [__] I marry you but that's
not a prenup and you got to get your own
crib you gotta have your own home and I
got mine now you got the keys you come
over whatever you want yeah
but I want to be up under your ass 24 7.
sometimes I just want to be by myself
smoking my little cigar and not doing
things I love it because sometimes you
might talk to [__] my facts and
sometimes I may not want to [__] talk
you know oh you're on the phone with
your mother she gonna made you mad I'm
hearing y'all I ain't got [__] I ain't
got time for this [__] I love it well
listen TK I appreciate your time that's
always a pleasure it's both you
gentlemen I see how you grown
um to sit here and to see that because I
tell people also every year your life
should get better of course and your
life's not getting better every year
reevaluate you're doing yourself you're
doing something wrong right
100 well I appreciate you man made your
pain yes sir champagne yes sir
appreciate you man oh an hour a day
you're gonna walk up and down the street
I got your word I got 100 when I come
back in a year he's gonna win the same
he's gonna look I'm gonna look different
watch my walk go look healthy as hell
yeah remember you're gonna see the
diabetes in the water take your clothes
off you want your woman to be looking at
you looking sexy
see if you want to do it for yourself
you're married
so I'm gonna give you a game watch this
I am sexy I'm gonna give you some games
I want you I want you to buy some nice
pajamas okay and some house shoes and
wear a robe around the house
watch this [__] it may sound crazy but
you're gonna look like a king when you
open the door and somebody other door
you've presented extremely well right
instead of coming to the door with
slides on socks and shorts and a t-shirt
so I'm like I come to work yeah
everything you do is your presentation
right and you want to have class and the
reason why I'm sharing I'm living on the
air because now when people see you in a
nice pair of pajamas you maybe have a
glass of water in your hand some fake
glasses put it together you're getting
lined up you're looking good right
so get a nice robe some nice house shoes
cut your hair yeah
keep you keep your line up take care of
yourself we'll get your pajama game
together get your roll together
give me an example of how this just
we're just tearing down James
but let me give you the game to prove my
point when Biggie was a bit puffy okay I
think he was just a regular [__] and
puppies girl at the time told puffy to
put that [__] in some fly-ass [__] and
when he started performing with the hat
this is the glasses everything nobody
was rocking Versace till biggie wolf's
side 100 and he became like a same thing
with Ross I know females who are like
sexually obsessed with Rick Ross yep
he's a overweight man who's very but
it's his presentation his attitude yes
there's girls who are [__] I know one
girl in particular who's like number one
in her spank bank is Rick Ross and I
don't get it wow yep I see it shout out
to Ross but he does have a certain when
he put suits on yes the [__] looks
smooth and a [__] that's the
same thing like with the robe man you
gotta have you guys You Gotta Wear that
belly with pride you guys in my belly
[Music]
three times
three I guess that every three months
here's what I want you to do and we're
gonna we're gonna go
two things I want you to do there's a
Thing Called Life Line Screening okay
you heard of it Lifeline screening is a
diagnosis of a doctor when you go in
they put these different things on you
right and they could tell you if you uh
lie before a stroke heart attack they
see how the blood is going through your
body and you they send that in the mail
you take that to your doctor because
doctors only ask you what is hurting you
right they don't go inside check all
that that's what you want you want to go
Lifeline screening right and I guarantee
you they're gonna save your life because
you ain't been to the doctor in 10 years
yeah
all right well we out we got to get
James to the doctor we gotta go